Hey Thoughty2 here.
The world is full of hidden wonders and sights
that will blow your mind.
Let's go on a journey to some of the weirdest
places on earth.
We start in Derweze, Turkmenistan where a
huge fiery crater is known to locals as "The
Door to Hell".
Whilst drilling at the site in 1971, soviet
geologists tapped into an underground cavern
filled with natural gas.
But the ground beneath the drilling rig collapsed,
leaving a hole 70 metres in diameter.
Fearing the cavern would leak poisonous gasses
the drilling team decided to burn it off.
They hoped it would burn out in a few days,
but it's still burning today, over 40 years
later.
Next to the US, specifically Yellowstone National
park in Wyoming.
Here you will find the world's third largest
hot spring, and one of the most beautiful.
Named Grand Prismatic Spring, this springs
vibrant colours are caused by its pigmented
bacteria.
Seasonal temperatures as well as levels of
chlorophyll and carotenoids in the spring,
greatly influence the tint of its bacteria,
and subsequently its colours.
Bacteria doesn't form in the centre because
the water is too hot to sustain bacterial
life.
Salar de Uyuni in Bolivia is home to the world's
largest salt flat, occupying the area of roughly
10,582 square kilometres (6,575 sq mi).
It was created when a prehistoric lake dried
up and left a salty crust behind.
When it rains the entire salt flat becomes
a giant mirror, and you can walk on top of
a near perfect reflection of the sky.
In South America amongst the Pakaraima's mountain
range sits the tabletop mountain Mount Roraima.
It's one of the oldest geological formations
on Earth, dating back over two billion years.
It serves as a triple border between Brazil,
Venezuela and Guyana.
Its 400 metre tall cliffs have meant it's
been cut off from human interaction for most
of history.
Subsequently the mountain's upper plateau
has it's own unique ecosystem and a staggering
30% of all the plant and animal species are
endemic to the mountain.
Which means they can only be found on this
mountain and nowhere else on earth.
But Mount Roraima isn't the only place on
earth with an isolated ecosystem, such places
are countless, but one of the most interesting
is Socotra in Yemen which is a small archipelago
in the Indian Ocean.
Because it's so isolated, one third of its
plant life is found nowhere else on the planet,
such as the Dragon's Blood Tree, named after
its blood red sap.
Have you ever wanted to step inside a glacier?
In Skaftafell, Iceland there is an ice cave
within glacier ice.
This unique cave is a result of a glacial
mill, which is a hole in the glacier.
Water flows down the hole and eventually melts
the ice to form a large cave.
Because glaciers are constantly moving, if
you stand inside the cave you can hear incredibly
loud cracking sounds as the ice above you,
and the cave itself moves millimetres along
the ground.
From one icy hemisphere to another, in the
Antarctic you'll find frozen waves.
But these waves are a result of melting, not
freezing.
The downwards pointing spikes are simply icicles.
Next to China for the world's most colourful
mountain range, the Zhangye Danxia landform
in Gansu.
This magnificent display of colours is the
result of red sandstone and mineral deposits
being laid down for over 24 million years.
Fancy a spot of scuba diving?
The imaginatively named, Great Blue Hole is
a popular submarine sinkhole and scuba diving
site just off the coast of Belize.
This natural phenomenon is 124 metres (407
ft) deep.
On Vaadhoo island in the Maldives is the Sea
of Stars.
Beautiful bioluminescent patterns can be seen
along the shore.
These lights are caused by marine microbes
called phytoplankton.
They contain a chemical called luciferase
which has the ability to create biological
light.
If you're feeling romantic you may want to
visit the Tunnel of Love in Klevan, Ukraine.
This hot spot for lovers is an active railway
line engulfed in a tunnel of leaves.
The tunnel was formed over many years as a
train which passed through the forest 3 times
a day slowly carved a tunnel through the trees.
But natural wonders also come in the manmade
variety, such as Fly Geyser in Nevada.
Located on the private Fly Ranch and cut off
from tourists, this geyser is a man-made phenomenon,
created by well drilling in 1964 whilst seeking
sources of geothermal energy.
The well was not capped correctly and dissolved
minerals started rising and accumulating.
The mound beneath the geyser is still growing
today and water is constantly being released.
Also man made is the hidden beach in the Marieta
Islands, Mexico.
This beautiful secluded beach is actually
the result of bombing.
The spot was bombed during target practice
by the Mexican government.
Chand Baori is a famous step well in the Indian
state of Rajasthan.
It was constructed in 800 CE.
Rajasthan state is extremely arid and the
intent of the step well was to conserve as
much water as possible during the hotter months.
The air constantly remains 5-6 degrees cooler
at the bottom, compared to the surface.
Therefore it was commonly used as a community
gathering place for locals during periods
of intense heat.